let's go to our caller from the two six  zero area code who is calling today from  two six oh I can hear me  yeah who's this sorry when I'm gonna  start with an only fans you said yeah  and only then because I think a great  guys like you would just you know really  you know you interestingly enough this  may be shocking to the audience but  you're not the what was your name by the  way Oh Jess you're not the only person  Jess who has suggested I start an only  fans but my understanding is it's  essentially like a porn site isn't it  yeah okay and and you want me to start  one okay I'm on cameo but I'm not on  only fans and I don't know that that's  gonna change anytime soon I'm sorry to  disappoint both men and women apparently  who want me to start that but I I don't  see it in my future Jess all right very  good just seem totally serious there  that was that was a serious phone call  as far as I can tell